i always wanted to play wolverine
it's not too late it is too late it's
not too late for kiara to play wolverine
i'm just going to leave
there i'm all good with it now
but that was i'm leaving that there
keanu is that real did you really want
to play wolverine
oh yeah frank miller's wolverine for
sure
that's keanu reeves in the 2020
interview with siriusxm's radio andy
saying that he's probably missed the
boat on playing his dream role wolverine
and he's cool with that so what do you
do when you're no longer able to play an
immortal
nearly unkillable badass with a penchant
for ultra violence
searching for the truth about his
identity
if you can you go ahead and create your
own violence
i'm cursed and compelled by it
has just signed a deal with netflix to
bring his comic book berserker to the
streaming service
with reeves producing and starring in
both the film adaptation and its anime
series follow-up
berserker is a story of a half-man
half-god with a mysterious past
who's up for killing pretty much anybody
the convergence of nerdy things here is
just
like it just blows my mind john wick
wolverine the anime
sign me up let's do this
are you excited for kiana's new projects
do you think he would have made a great
wolverine or
are there other comic book characters
you think that he'd be perfect for let's
talk about it
in the comments below
you